you would certainly have heard more than
once that in the distant future people
will be able to easily travel between
galaxies unfortunately unlike what you
can see in sci-fi movies this
opportunity is not going to present
itself anytime soon however we're quite
able to observe our galaxy's neighbors
even today there are currently dozens of
galaxies nearest to us known to science
large and dwarf ones with the data about
them continuously flowing in of course
it is too early to talk about a friendly
visit there but if a chance does present
itself where can we set out first and
what is there beyond the boundaries of
the Milky Way galaxy is a common name
for a system of stars clusters
interstellar gas dust dark matter and
planets which all are bound together by
one gravitational energy all objects in
a galaxy are in motion with respect to
the general center of its mass as a rule
these are really remote astronomical
objects with the distances to them
measured in mega parsecs we can make out
only several of them with the naked eye
the Andromeda galaxy seen in the
northern hemisphere the large and small
Magellanic Clouds seen in the southern
hemisphere and the m33 galaxies in the
Triangulum constellation seen from the
northern hemisphere as well the exact
number of galaxies in the observable
part of the universe isn't known but
their number may well reach 2 trillion
only in the 20th century was it made
possible to observe some of them by the
early 1990s not more than 30 galaxies
were registered where stars were visible
and which were part of the local group
that is the cluster of galaxies forming
one large hole known as the Virgo
supercluster
after the launch of the Hubble telescope
in April 1990 however the inflow of
information about new galaxies soared
dramatically today they're subdivided
into several general classes the first
class is satellite or companion galaxies
which are objects orbiting around a
larger galaxy due to the gravity of the
latter the second class is spiral
galaxies which are peculiar for the
central bulge cocooned in a disc and the
third class is irregular galaxies
typically unsuited to either the
proposed categories as a rule they are
chaotic formations with neither clear
nucleus nor spiral arms lenticular or SL
galaxies elliptical galaxies and barred
spiral galaxies like our own Milky Way
fall into this category to the
approximate diameter of each of them
ranges from 5 to 250 kilo parsecs or 16
to 800 thousand light-years just to
compare the diameter of the Milky Way is
30 kilo parsecs that is a hundred
thousand light years the largest
galaxies known today is called IC 1101
and bursts the diameter of over 600 kilo
parsecs the principle problem in
studying the structure of a galaxy is
the mystery of the dark matter today the
dark matter is believed to account for
up to 90% of the overall mass of a given
galaxy alternatively another galaxy may
be completely devoid of it but which of
these objects can be defined as the
nearest to us many would argue that is
the Andromeda galaxy that is the closest
which is located 2.5 2 million
light-years away however this is the
closest object among the largest spiral
galaxies
as for the closest galaxies a
hypothetical Canis Major dwarf galaxy
should be named this astronomical object
belongs to the local group as well the
galaxy contains a comparatively high
percentage of red giant stars and
presumably a billion regular stars it is
classified as an irregular galaxy and is
officially considered our nearest
neighbor the galaxies located 25,000
light-years away from the solar system
and 42,000 light years from the center
of the Milky Way this object was
discovered in November 2003 by an
international team of astronomers in
spite of its closed location to the
earth the galaxy wasn't easy to spot
because it is located beyond the plain
of the Milky Way in the area with
stellar gas and dust / density our
second closest neighbor is the
Sagittarius dwarf elliptical galaxy
which used to be considered the first
one as well it is a satellite galaxy
with a clearly defined elliptical
structure with its orbit passing over
the Milky Way the object contains four
globular stellar clusters with the first
of them discovered in 1994 which led to
the discovery of the galaxy itself its
diameter makes up about 10,000
light-years it is about 70,000
light-years away from the earth and
50,000 light-years away from the core of
the Milky Way it is thanks to this
galaxy that the Milky Way may have
obtained its arm structure this
conclusion is based on numerical
modeling it was arrived at by
researchers from the University of
Pittsburgh according to their version
the arms of our galaxy may have been
obtained as a result of a collision with
the Sagittarius dwarf elliptical galaxy
this object is currently in the process
of merging with the Milky Way which
should be noted that it has passed
through the plane of our galaxy several
times the last time took place about a
hundred and fifty million year
ago which agrees with the data received
by the gaia telescope when speaking
about our nearest neighbors one can't
but mentioned the large and the small
Magellanic Clouds two dwarf galaxies
have satellites of the Milky Way the
Large Magellanic Cloud is 163 thousand
light-years away from us that is a
distance twice as big as the diameter of
our galaxy the Large Magellanic Cloud
finds itself in the area between the
Dorado and Mensa costal Asians in the
southern hemisphere which is the reason
why it is unlikely to be seen from most
of Eurasia the galaxies approximately
ten times smaller than the Milky Way and
contains approximately 30 billion stars
the mass of the Large Magellanic Cloud
is about 300 times as small as that of
our galaxy however it does not prevent
it from holding the 4th place among all
the local group galaxies in terms of its
mass beaten only by the Andromeda galaxy
the Milky Way galaxy and the Triangulum
galaxy one of the best-known objects in
this galaxy is wo H g64 a star
considered to be one of the largest
known to science
it's radius is 1540 times that of the
Sun hypothetically placed in the core of
the solar system it would reach as far
as the orbit of Saturn with its edges
the Milky Way and the Large Magellanic
Cloud are expected to collide in
approximately 2.4 billion years time its
neighbor a small magellanic cloud should
also be mentioned it is a dwarf galaxy -
and is enveloped in neutral hydrogen the
small cloud is 60 kilo parsecs away from
us that is approximately 195 thousand
light-years it is located in the - karna
constellation and has the appearance of
a faint spot about three degrees in size
1.5 billion stars are thought to be
found in the Small Magellanic
cloud however they're not visible from
most of Eurasia either according to the
data published in September 2014 the
Milky Way is likely to swallow up this
object as well in four billion years
time to date the number of satellite
galaxies in the Milky Way equals 18 but
the number of large systems closest to
us reaches 115 this is hardly the full
list of these objects because new dwarf
systems are discovered now from time to
time not far from the Milky Way
pinpointing and exploring objects like
that is a rather arduous task however
the search for nearest galaxies remains
one of the chief objectives in astronomy
today their discovery might give us
insights into new planets similar to the
earth and might lead to the discovery of
life-forms in the nearest parts of the
universe I hope you enjoyed the video
and were excited to find out more about
our nearest galactic neighbors thanks to
advanced technologies we're able to
receive a lot of data on the formation
of nearest cosmic structures today based
on these we can arrive at conclusions
about our Milky Way as well
it's an our power to share this
information so that these achievements
become known to the widest audience
possible if you're inspired by these
discoveries as much as I am share this
video with your friends or just hit the
like and the bell buttons let's keep in
touch
[Music]
you